right up into them five to shoot
Leonard's gonna try another one been
getting destroyed with this principle
the switch cousins on the small again of
someone like Quinn cook Leonard till the
rim pull-up jumper got it Kawhi Leonard
taking over here in Game five mayfleet
Pines Thompson Thompson finds an opening
three-point is up it's good klay
Thompson from downtown and it's back to
three Murray gets a look fires away ties
the game Steph Curry from downtown who
say how Steph Curry look at the
incredible shot making ability moving
without the rock catches it in rhythm
turns Lots loaves and fires very pushing
it up and fleet in pursuit big Adama
back out to green Thompson one fake one
dribble one shot got it
Golden State retakes the lead defensive
and shooting responds the semi
transition the excellent extra pass and
then the shot fake the side dribble and
then knock down three warriors up three
Leonard back up van fleet that fleet
kicks it out Lowry Lowry for the win
won't go and they'll be a game six in
Oakland and it was a great job of double
teaming Leonard so he couldn't